the most jaw-dropping discovery that
I've had during my career so far was
actually the discovery of practice of
place your legs under the Antarctic Ice
Sheet we saw 10 meters of elevation
change over two years on this particular
part of the ice sheet and it was the
kind of signal that you showed you your
colleagues and they said no that can't
be right that it's got to be an error in
the data I mean and so you have several
days we were back and forth we worked
out it had to be a sublease or Lake it
was really exciting because this is a
whole new phenomenon that we didn't
really understand before and the fact
that it was happening underneath ice
streams where it can actually change ice
flow rates towards the ocean and it's a
process that we need to have in models
that was really nice really nice
discovery after we discovered the lakes
we instrumented them with GPS and it's
become a very big field of exploration
now so we've had drill a drilling team
go down and actually drill into one of
the lakes or
it's about refunded to drill into
another one as well so we're going to
have samples in two different lakes to
try to descend like the water that some
of the lakes and what kind of life
exists
in these Lakes and how long the lakes
have been there and something about the
history what they mean for the ice
sheets
you